[Music]
hey you guys
or one person whoever has been there
well we usually would play would like
let the
starting zoom thing go for a little
while but uh we don't have time today we
don't really have time today because we
have to do this like uh in less than
half an hour yeah some of our friends
might come over
yeah and i i only just found out about
it
two minutes ago if they do come over
i'll just let them in we'll have them on
the show it's angel and her and her
boyfriend but uh we're trying to get a
head start on this
last night we watched this uh
documentary
as a documentary yeah it's a documentary
about louisiana called gator bait
and uh surprisingly
good flick it's a pretty good movie it's
it's it's it's sucking um
what do you call it cracker exploitation
it's a crackers rotation exploitation
that placed it it was inspirational
exploiting anything southern they were
exploiting the [ __ ] out of it
uh
kind of like
kind of like the the southern version of
dolomite you know
dolomite was black exploitation this is
crack exploitation uh if you like that
kind of movie you'd like it this is just
kind of like
it's just a very kind of
fantasy version
of the south it's kind of like what
yankees think the south is like and wish
it was like and wish they could do i
guess not as probably not a single
southern person in this movie
but it's still a pretty good movie it's
[ __ ] it's
it it's kind of like i spit on your
grave but better it's a lot better than
spit on your graves if you had i
disagree i like i spit in your grave a
lot better but honestly i spit on your
grave came out like after this so but
well the thing about this this movie i
had kind of heard of it but i've never
seen it it came out 1974.
and shutter just added it not too long
ago so i was like kind of scrolling
through and i said to tom i was like oh
gator bait that sounds like something
that's totally right up your alley so
you should probably watch that
especially since it's you know set in
the bayou and everything yeah and i kind
of feel like it's weird because the
wikipedia page if you go to is like
nothing it's like a sentence and then
like like two sentences talking about
the plot and that's about it
so
this movie i what it's pretty much
exactly what you expect like like when
you look at the poster
it's but you know what it wasn't quite
as
i expected it to be more
sleazy and more gory no it's actually
yeah so it's not as sleazy or it's
pretty sleazy but it wasn't as sleazy or
gory as i was expecting and actually it
was shot really nicely i think it was
because
of
you know where they shot it i mean it's
really hard to [ __ ] up a landscape that
looks like that i mean it's so i kind of
feel like the swamps where they shot it
like almost sort of became a character
in its own right yeah the basic story
here is uh cajuns versus rednecks all
right with the two different ethnics
yeah which you think they're the same
thing but they're not okay
um
you could say that i'm from a redneck
family in mississippi but all my cousins
are are cajuns uh
and surprisingly they look like
this redhead i i can show you pictures
to prove it my cousins kind of look like
that she was uh
the girl playing
the part
uh is uh she's kind of like the star
she's a ex playboy
bunny
yeah she was the playmate of the year
though yeah claudia jennings her name is
she actually does a a pretty good job in
the movie uh she's being accused of a
murder she didn't commit and some
corrupt
corrupt sheriff what a corrupt sheriff
believes his deputy who's his son
uh that this girl killed this guy
but it turned out the son did it by
accident because they were trying to
they were chasing her in a boat trying
to get some ass and
uh she ran and a [ __ ] fighting suit
type of deal and dude fell down and
accidentally blew his buddy's head off
and he blamed it on that girl
it turned out there was like a long
history between this group of rednecks
and this
in this little cajun family now for
people who don't know what a cajun is
cajuns came from the word occasion
and the occasions were
they were french people uh in louisiana
and around 1700 1720 around that time
they got conquered by the british empire
um
they called them occasions
and then later on they became americans
during the louisiana purchase when
thomas jefferson bought louisiana so
that's how they be they're kind of like
our version of kind of like the french
canadians kinda but they were swamp
people
and uh
they're still around
another word from the creoles
and
there were some ethnic differences
between them you had white ones you had
some of them that were mixed and some of
them that were black but most of them
were white occasions
cajun is a country
creole
but that's what it is so
you know you hear the reason why i said
that is because they throw the word [ __ ]
ass around a lot a lot of people from
outside the south wouldn't know what
that was [ __ ] ass is a redneck term to
mean cajun or occasion [ __ ] ass
yeah they say that a lot ass or cooney
they call it kuni or kunas thank you
victor for your super chat hey i
finished house of leaves
so did you like it because i can't
remember if you said that was the first
time that you'd read it or not it's like
i said it's an experience it's not just
a book but uh but yeah he's like he's
like the first thing i did was go watch
your book review
yeah um yeah so
i kind of was expecting this kind of
reminded me like i said it
the thing it reminded me of the
strongest was i spit on your grave but
it wasn't as i mean i really like i spit
on your grave um but it's really hard to
watch just because like that rape scene
is just like so prolonged and like so
horrific
this one
i guess it kind of gets classed in even
like on the wikipedia thing it even gets
classed in with like rape revenge movies
which it sort of is yeah don't buy one
girl and it's not the hero well i mean
the thing about well they well they kind
of go into i mean the the instigating
instant incident that happens at the
beginning where the dumb sheriff like
accidentally shoots the other dumb
redneck um
that happens in the course of an
attempted rape uh because they're trying
to catch her
uh you know what i mean because she's
out in the swamp poaching and i guess
she's been out there for a long time
like with her family or whatever
so
so then she gets accused of the murder
but then they kind of talk about like
one of the conversations that they all
have
is that one of the dumb rednecks i can't
remember which one um did actually try
to rape her before and she cut his balls
off but you don't see that that's just
something that they bring up now later
on
when the dumb rednecks are looking for
her
and they find her cabin where she also
has like a younger sister and a younger
brother who's mute
uh the sister's not mute but the brother
is
and the sister is supposed to be what 15
i'm not sure i hope the actress was
older than that because she gets naked
in this and it's supposed to be 15. and
she looks pretty young i gotta say so i
don't really know like how old she was
but i think in the movie she's supposed
to be uh 15. now there is um the the
guys do actually like do an attempted
rape runner which again is a pretty
horrific scene i have a hard time like
watching that kind of stuff in movies
but um but so that's pretty horrific but
then i don't know if i should
spoil it because like some [ __ ] that
happens i was uh not expecting yeah
you're not expecting it i was just kind
of like
yeah
yeah but that actually added to the
movie it did and um
it's not a bad movie in terms of
look the whole thing is one big
stereotype okay you just gotta have to
get over that uh but that but it is it
is kind of based in it is kind of based
in truth
but a lot of the truth that they're
talking about was something that maybe
like wait maybe the way it was in the
very early 1900s late 1800s
and so that's kind of where some of the
stereotypes are coming from
but
if you actually grow up in those areas
or you're related to those people
they're not actually like that
it's just
it's not as mad max as that and they're
doing things like spitting on a cop
a small town cop you spit on a small
town [ __ ] they would kill you
out there all right you couldn't get
away with that uh there's a bunch of
[ __ ] that happens that in southern
culture even now you i don't know how
much has changed like in a recent decade
or so but no you couldn't get away with
that okay
local cops were so
much part of the system especially back
in that era no one would ever testify
against them they were all related to
the judges and everything it was just
one big
ball of nepotism a small-town cop or
little sheriff and his deputies they
were all related to each other
they ran to town if you spit on one
they'd kill you
you disappear well what ended up
happening in this one though it was just
kind of like the deputy that
accidentally shot one of the rednecks
and then lied and said that she did it
and then his dad who's the sheriff
them and the rednecks didn't really get
along but then they kind of like teamed
up
to chase the girl yeah and the family so
so there was kind of like a lot of
tensions between the cops and the
rednecks while they were trying but
because they were going after um you
know a shared enemy i guess
yeah this is this is being filmed in the
70s supposed to be taking place in the
70s and for me it was kind of cool
because i was growing up as a kid
visiting mississippi and going to the
bayou in louisiana and stuff and hanging
out with relatives and you see i'm
seeing [ __ ] and architecture that i kind
of i kind of remember everything is
filmed in front of something abandoned
to make it look more dilapidated and
older than it really is you know like
it's in the 1970s but they're always
shooting in front of some kind of
abandoned shack that was built in the
late 1800s and they're pretending like
they live in it
but it really would have been it would
have been like trailers and [ __ ]
brick houses and stuff you know in
reality but uh some of the [ __ ] was kind
of like based on fantasy like the
opening thing the opening scene is they
got this fantastic playboy buddy [ __ ]
she's a ginger and [ __ ] she's riding
through the bayou in a [ __ ] bot in
her in her [ __ ] boat
and scantily clad
and like
i told jenny at the time no that you
were dreaming that you saw a girl that
looked like that out in the [ __ ]
bayou uh you'd have them they'd look
like that but they weren't made up i
mean she had makeup on
yeah well yeah i mean if you're in a
movie you pretty much have makeup on
right
it looks like that was no makeup they do
have people that look like that though
you know what i mean uh like uh and the
girls mostly have are like my cousins
they all all their names begin with k
it's like casey and catherine and cat
and katrina and just it's just k names
certain generations you know we're like
that it's just funny but this is a
picture
of my cousin cat and she's a cajun and
that's that's what they look like that's
a modern one
but you see it's just like a normal kind
of
person
but from that family that's how i got my
french middle name because my middle
name is actually francois
because uh and my grandfather named
bolivar which is spanish but
just the
the movie kind of just brings up the the
multi-ethnic
background of the deep south can we talk
too about like the redneck family are
sort of like introduced with
one of the brothers who they say is kind
of like not all there he was touched
yeah yeah
he was touched
but um yeah he kind of had like a
learning disorder let's call it a
learning disorder um and he's trying to
essentially rape his sister yeah while
she's hanging out the laundry telling
her how it was like man you're looking
good and that kind of
not just
70s model from either playboy or hustler
or jugs magazine that girl was [ __ ]
built and they got her in a damn her
slip barefoot doing damn laundry like
it's 1920s hillbillies and [ __ ] you know
it's just kind of funny but it made for
a good movie well you know what's weird
is that so they got like claudia
jennings who was the playmate of the
year and she's like the main star her
character's name is desiree by the way
yeah desiree and now they do not show
her she doesn't get naked at any point
right she's just pretty much they do
like kind of some down blousey kind of
[ __ ] and it's like i think maybe you
kind of see a nipple at one point and
you know you can see her ass cheeks like
with her little daisy dukes on and stuff
but i'm pretty sure so i feel like maybe
it was contractually obligated that she
didn't do nudity in the movie because i
don't think she was naked in the movie
no just there was the one scene where
they were kind of like showing the girl
like kind of bathing in the swamp and it
was and i thought it was her but i was
like oh that's the sister that's the
younger sister like because i didn't
realize until they showed her like more
close up
but so she's yeah so she was like the
only one that got naked in it and like i
said i'm really hoping she was over 18
because she looked very young and she
was and she was supposed to be 15 in the
movie the only girl that got naked in
the movie was supposed to be 15. so yeah
so
um
i will say like i kind of it was
expecting this to be
trashier than it was yeah
um and gorier than it was most of the
people that get killed because i was i
was thinking more along the lines of
like i said the later i spit on your
grave was like i want to see some like
dicks get cut off and [ __ ] like that
but
most of the guys like when she's doing
the revenge most of them she just shot
him to be honest she did and i was like
i thought i thought that maybe she
should have made him suffer more and i
thought too that because it's called
gator bait
and they get into this whole
uh discussion about when desiree was a
little girl
like when she
got in trouble or i i think that like
when she was a little girl and also her
mom like their dad was kind of like a
jackal and he would like tie them with
rope and like put them in the swamp
until the gators would come and then
they'd yank him out like oh funny you
know what i mean so like gator bait you
know what i mean okay there's a bunch of
stories about gator bait gator bait is a
is an urban legend yeah southerners did
not do that to anybody
yeah but there is there yeah there are
urban legends about it there's a
wikipedia page joke about doing that
yeah and uh there was like
in the 20s certainly these little towns
the children got eaten all right they
got they get eaten here in florida by
alligators well yeah that happened just
like a few years ago right
and um back in the early 1900s
the kids that were mostly getting eaten
were african-american kids because they
lived in those areas
so it was kind of like a joke that the
alligators were eating all the black
kids not really a joke it's just that
they were
it was a meme that all the black kids
were getting eaten by alligators so they
would sell these postcards of little
black kids sitting up on top of stump
with alligators around them now they
weren't real photographs they were
usually like doctored photographs and
it'd be like something like you know oh
save me that kind of [ __ ] or so you know
alligator that's still pretty [ __ ] up
yeah yeah but they have people today
thinking that white people were feeding
black kids to alligators no that did not
happen they were just i mean it might
have happened one time or something like
that everybody just said somebody to
some alligator at some point or another
you had crime happening you know what i
mean but uh no that wasn't part of the
culture what was part of the culture is
the making kind of like making light of
being eaten by damn wild animals you
know this is it was a frontier
there was a frontier civilization for
hundreds of years
and people got eaten
well like you said
nowadays everybody yeah nowadays people
get eaten not as much obviously because
things are more developed nowadays they
don't live the way they used to yeah and
in in but it still does happen in
louisiana a lot of people lived in
something called p row which is like a
floating house
which is a trip all right and you get
eaten off one of those or they had
houses on the banks on stilts and little
kids running around all the little
children and [ __ ] and they they couldn't
help but play their kids the alligators
eat them
you know
and uh you know they were eating
everybody but evidently a lot of it was
black kids getting eaten because that's
they were more likely to live in those
conditions yeah and cajuns too
cajuns too get eaten
swamp people camp guys said the ranger
at the okefenokee swamp told me he had
seen people tie their dog leash up and
walk off for a few minutes and hater
would get the dog yeah
um
honestly that's why i don't i don't
really like
letting if you live around here and
there's water around i would not let my
cats and dogs run around outside they
would stage all kind of photographs
they'd kill some alligators and cut the
heads off and people would climb inside
the jaws and hold on to a tree for dear
life and all you see is the damn person
holding on the tree and the head of the
alligator and you'd think it was a
photograph of a person being swallowed
it wasn't all right
if you ever see an alligator get
somebody it happens like that and you're
not strong enough to hold on to a tree
that alligator [ __ ] rip your arms off
bam
only take the drag underneath the water
and damn drowned you
so there was once they once an alligator
it was big enough to swallow you got a
hold of you that's it
yeah i don't think you're really getting
away from that and it was there's videos
of it you're on the bank and then boom
you're in the water there's no struggle
instant
pretty much there's no time to grab
anything
so
but what i was saying was that because
the movie movie's called gator bait and
they actually like talk about that trope
as something that happened to desiree
and her mom when they were younger
i kind of was expecting that they had
set that up
um that that like the last guy that she
was getting revenge on that she would do
that to him like just leave him tied in
the swamp so he couldn't so i thought
that was good what was going to happen
and that's not that doesn't really
happen they named the movie after they
made it and it was it was more of a play
on jail bait
yeah
there was a bunch of movies like this
that came out jail bait child bride yeah
it was all like they were trying to say
you know it was like jail bait out in
the alligator in the swamps that's what
they're talking about
and uh interestingly this movie was
actually uh written directed produced by
a woman actually uh um
husband and wife team
beverly and ferd sebastian
uh they i think they only made
five or six movies they're all kind of
like exploitation movies they made a
sequel to this as well which is called
what was it called again it was called
gator bait two cajun justice or
something like that um i think it was
like it didn't come out till the 90s i
want to say i think it was like much
later that it came out but i haven't
seen that but i actually
the movie was a little it's not very
long it's only like 83 minutes or
something like that i thought it dragged
a little bit in places like because a
lot of it was just like long chase
scenes and [ __ ] like that but honestly
um
it was like much better than i was
expecting like it was shot much better
than i was expecting good movie there's
a sequel i want to see it too yeah
that's what i was just saying and um as
i said the only complaint is that i
think i was kind of hoping it would be
sleazier i was kind of hoping it would
be gorier
uh that it would be smuttier
that the kills would have been more
satisfying like i said i kind of wish
that some of the people gotten killed in
ways other than just being shot
um you know i think that would have been
cool and like i said i think it would
have been cool like to tie in the whole
gator bait thing with like at least one
of the rednecks getting
you know fed to an alligator
would have been cool but i guess they
couldn't really afford i think they
named it that app to do that
couldn't i think they couldn't really
afford to do that maybe
so maybe that's why it's like well we
don't really have the special effects
budget to show somebody like even
pretend getting eaten by an alligator so
you know what i mean uh so maybe that's
why but it's totally worth watching like
if you're into 70s kind of like
exploitation i guess it's exploitation
yeah
i'm not i'm not sure what the what the
preferred nomenclature is yeah uh
because i know that there's a lot of it
is it might be it might be exploitation
there's a lot of [ __ ] uh uh
stereotypes to get southerners you know
dumb stupid lazy uh [ __ ] criminal uh
kind of like rock stupid yeah sister
[Laughter]
yeah pretty much any like any any
stereotype right
it's just like and there are no
southerners making this movie
yeah they're all it's all fake accents
and stuff you know but i like that they
did i mean as i said i kind of feel like
the the atmosphere like the setting of
this is what really makes it because the
swamp looks really really cool yeah and
the cajun girl's the hero in it she's
kind of like a uh
she's kind of like a [ __ ] swamp
valkyrie you know she [ __ ] gets the
best of all the gets the best of all the
men that are trying to [ __ ] get her
and she you know it's almost like a
duke's a hazard kind of uh yeah can't
can't say i was a real fan of her cajun
accent if that's what it was um she
doesn't talk much
which is probably good
but it's i mean it wasn't terrible but
to be honest well when she first started
talking i was like is she russian what
is this what is that i said is she gonna
go get moose and squirrel that's kind of
what it sounded like for a second
but um yeah so i so the cajun accent not
the best but you know what i mean uh
yeah but like i said yeah it was pretty
fun this is up there with like a
dolomite movie yeah
i think it wasn't quite as like funny
silly or funny as that
um and i will say the one scene in this
where the [ __ ] happens to the sister was
actually pretty horrifying yeah yeah uh
so i mean so much so that i kind of
gasped think like hills have eyes mad
max
i spit on your grave like that not quite
as yeah if you like that kind of stuff
or if you like like um like hg lewis and
stuff like 2000 maniacs or something
like that um you'd probably dig this
it's not as
gory it's not a sleazy it's actually
like a pretty decent
flick i thought like but i wish it had
been more violent or like more over the
top but it was like still pretty good
way way better than it has super chat
dave juices tom is gay bate
[Laughter]
drum roll please i'll see myself
oh my god making money with what god
gave me man
that's what everybody's gotta do man you
gotta do what you gotta do
that's right
i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna get you some pasties and teach
you to twirl them come up in here
i got i got some black booty shorts i'll
put them on put my [ __ ] boots on back
here like that
just tape over my nipples and [ __ ]
[ __ ] all these looking homos be
spending sending all kinds of money to
me i got my huge [ __ ] gay fan base
behind me there you go i had to [ __ ]
only fans will just [ __ ]
jump to life man it'll be a millionaire
well yeah we'll get on that
you know
[Laughter]
tom's just always talking he doesn't he
doesn't ever do anything that he says
he's gonna do it's just time so like
don't get all excited no he's never
gonna do it exactly like yeah yeah i'll
pay for that
well you only need a few kind of like
heavy hitters like i have rollers man
right that's all you need yeah but uh
yeah so it turned out i know this one's
kind of short but like i said uh we have
people coming i unexpectedly didn't know
that there was like so a couple of our
friends are coming over yeah they're
actually coming over early they're
supposed to be at four
oh would have plenty of time well that's
all right but uh no they're on it
they cut that down to more like 3 30.
yeah okay well that's all right now i
will say too that um we've already
watched all the movies for the matinee
so
uh we didn't actually mean to do this
but they're all animal themed yep so we
thought i was like oh that's kind of
neat how that happened we saw one tea
recommended nightwing nightwing yeah it
was good we're gonna review it
and also the uh nicholas cage movie yep
pig pig saw that one too we saw that one
too so uh so those are the next two that
we're gonna do on the matinee so it's
all it's animal week
on the matinee show all right so um like
i said sorry it's so short but we kind
of gotta cut it short so we can go and
meet up with the people
so have a good rest your weekend you
guys and we will see you guys again
tomorrow afternoon
bye